All right.
So New York Times bestselling author and Co Creator of the whole 30 program has
helped millions of people,
uh,
achieve the weight loss and health goals.
And we're really excited to have her here today to talk hot on the heels.
I've heard at latest book release,
uh,
food freedom forever,
letting go a bad habit,
guilt and anxiety around food only released yesterday.
So we are right at the cusp of it and we're excited to have her here to talk to
us about what that's all about with the whole 30th and answer all our questions.
So please join me in welcoming with that to talk the Google.
Yeah,
that's a pleasure to have you here today.
Thank you.
I'm really excited dated.
I'm very excited.
Yeah.
Um,
as a person who's always super interested in all like the latest food crazes and
exercised phases as most of us are,
um,
it's really great to have you here.
I said you can kind of navigate things,
Beth and pal if you buy your eyes and all of that,
but I'm excited.
Perfect.
So,
I mean a lot of these people,
I already know all that,
the whole 30 am it's a very well known program and uh,
pretty amazing.
But tell us a little bit about it just to get us gun.
Sure.
So you can think about the whole 30 like pushing the reset button with your
health,
your habits,
and your relationship with food.
So for 30 days you'll eliminate foods that the scientific literature and our
clinical experience have shown to be really commonly problematic to varying
degrees across the broad range of people.
So you pull that stuff out completely for 30 days and you're going to evaluate
what changes,
energy,
sleep,
digestion,
mood scan,
athletic performance,
recovery cravings,
any kind of symptoms,
migraines,
asthma,
allergies,
all of this stuff.
You're going to see what happens in the absence of some of these potentially
problematic triggers at the end of the 30 days.
You then put those foods back in very carefully and systematically,
one at a time,
like a scientific experiment and you pay attention to what changes.
So does your digestion and get worst as your skin breakout.
Does that like shoulder pain comeback?
It allows you to figure out how food impacts you individually because there's no
one size fits all and it lets you create the perfect diet for you going forward.
So who is the whole 34 is that for anyone?
Like anyone can do that.
I think everyone in the whole world to do the whole 30 but that's just me.
You know,
we have a lot of medical doctors who are using our program with their patients
and seeing amazing results with things like high blood pressure,
high cholesterol,
type two diabetes,
autoimmune conditions.
But you don't have to be sick to benefit from the whole 30 so if you're just
looking for improved energy,
managing your cravings through reducing digestive distress or weight loss,
even though that's not the main focus of our program,
the whole 30 is for you.
Okay.
And so tell us a little bit more about what we can have on the whole authority.
We don't go that what we
can.
I like that.
I always like starting with the Kennedys because the list of no's can be a
little intimidating on the whole 30 so let's start with what you will be eating.
And I'm going to paint a really good picture.
So meat,
seafood and eggs ideally naturally raised and fed,
but you can have a animal protein and we encourage a moderate portion with every
meal.
So it's certainly not like meat,
meat,
meat.
It's not a carnivorous plan.
It's actually really moderate portions.
You're eating lots and lots of plants,
so lots of vegetables,
fresh fruit,
we're not afraid of things like potatoes,
sweet potatoes or fruit as a whole.
Natural kind of nutrient dense food.
You're eating good healthy fats.
So things like Avocado,
olives,
olive oil,
duck fat,
ghee,
coconut oil and coconut products.
And then you're doing herbs and spices and people who do whole 30 recipes like
those who guest post on our whole 30 recipes,
Instagram feed.
Get incredibly creative with these really hardy,
nourishing,
whole 30 minutes.
So if I wanted the Super Paleo double fudge,
whatever,
as long as the ingredients are like fake fudge,
can I,
oh,
you're setting me up now,
aren't you?
So there is a rule in the whole 30 that says you're not allowed to recreate
baked goods,
treats,
desserts,
junk foods with technically compliant ingredients.
So there is a way to make whole 30 compliant pancakes or muffins or cookies.
But remember the whole 30 is about changing your health,
but also your habits and your emotional relationship with food.
And these comfort foods are what make us feel so out of control.
We start eating and we can't stop eating them.
So if you're trying to change your habits and your relationship with food and
you eat pancakes,
muffins,
and cookies,
and then you do the whole 30 and continue to eat pancakes,
muffins,
and cookies,
how much are those things going to change?
So we do have a rule that says that's a no,
no.
So what about,
so you said we can have grit.
Yay.
I have this thing about fear.
I have a friend who says that.
Um,
no,
I never got that off of fruit that you're fine.
But if you found my fruit now and I have every morning and every afternoon
working here,
you'd be like,
I think I'm not like the person who might be able to do that as a dessert
replacement or whatever.
So again,
you know,
we don't generally encourage dessert replacement because even if it's a
healthier choice,
but we want to do is get you out of the habit of dessert.
Like I don't want you to feel like you have to have something sweet before the
meal can feel complete.
So if you want dessert occasionally,
like great eat at,
that's fantastic.
But I don't want you to feel like it's necessary.
I'm not afraid,
excuse me,
and not afraid of eating fruit,
but I don't want you to do is use fruit to satisfy your sugar cravings.
So if every day at three o'clock are used to having a snickers bar and then you
do the whole 30 and everyday at three o'clock,
you're like,
okay,
well I can't do a snickers bar,
so I'm going to do a Lara bar.
It's a better food choice,
but you're still feeding your brain the sugar that it's throwing a temper
tantrum for.
So you're not actually changing anything in that pattern.
So it's not just about what you're eating,
it's about why you're eating it and some of the emotional reasons behind that
relationship with that particular food.
So how does the whole 30 or they,
you get us those emotional relationships,
what do you,
you just don't eat it if you're having a sugar craving,
what do it like?
Yeah,
well let me know.
You know a lot of these traditional diets just ask you to like white knuckle
your way through them,
right?
They don't provide a lot of rationale.
They don't provide support.
They don't provide a big community.
They're not giving you alternatives to not eating the cookie at nine o'clock at
night.
So all you're doing is like willpower white knuckling your way through it,
thinking about what you're going to eat on day 31 they're like Carb,
a Palooza that you're going to have,
right.
What we do on the whole 30 is provide alternatives.
So because we limit those comfort foods that you would normally reach for and
because we've got really strong recommendations against like,
okay,
well yes,
they're just homemade plantain chips,
but if you feel like you're not in control when you eat them,
is that really what you want for your whole 30 we forced people to find other
ways to comfort themselves,
to reward themselves,
to self sooth,
to show love with other people in their lives so that at the end of the program
you actually have some new habits to fall back on.
Not just the same habits with different foods.
What kinds of things can we use besides food to South Sudan?
Yeah,
you know it's funny,
it is tough,
but I said on Instagram the other day and so many people responded to it like
you're not looking for a cookie.
You're looking for a connection.
And so often what I find is people who rely on food for those emotional like to
fill that emotional hole,
like you're not going to find that at the bottom of a bag of potato chips.
And we all know this,
but we don't know what else to do.
So we end because the food is super normally stimulating,
incredibly rewarding,
and it's got low satiety factors like we over consume and then we feel even
worse about ourselves.
And then we say we're not going to do that again except that we do because we
don't know what else to do.
And I find interpersonal connection to be so key in relieving anxiety and stress
and having that motivation and that accountability and giving and receiving
love.
So I think the next time you find yourself in that situation where you're
reaching for food that you don't really want but you don't know what else to do,
reach out to someone else instead go see a friend,
you know,
text message,
phone call,
make it as personal as you can.
And I,
I really would find it hard to believe that that didn't relieve or fill you up
with what you are looking for.
Right.
And you have a whole,
a whole,
whole 30 community right to yes.
To reach out to you.
Yes.
The whole 30 community as incredibly robust,
fiercely loyal.
And I think one of the most positive and welcoming communities online.
We've got almost 2 million photos,
hashtag total 30 on Instagram right now.
I mean,
it is thriving and people are connecting with each other.
So if you don't have someone at home or in your community that you're doing the
whole 30 with,
you can come to my house and we'll make sure that you stay motivated and
accountable.
We'll answer your questions,
we'll provide you with support.
I have a lot of people who will snapchat me and say like,
I really want to cook you today.
I don't know what else to do.
And sometimes all they need is someone to say like,
you're not going out like that.
And they're okay and they keep going.
So I mean,
this is how connected I am to our community and my entire team.
So yeah,
I really am super proud of our whole 30 years.
That's great.
That's really great.
Um,
so the person who like,
I'm going to have a cookie today,
I can't resist.
They actually do it on the whole 30 program.
Then what happened?
So ideally with the whole 30 if you go off plan,
you start over and it's not because we're trying to be like a hazing or like the
bootcamp as Paleo because the basis,
the foundation of the whole 30 is an elimination diet.
You are eliminating these foods to see whether or not they work for you.
And the analogy I like to use this,
say you have 10 cats and you want to know if you're allergic to cats,
so you get rid of nine of your cats.
Do you feel better?
Like maybe,
but you still have a cat.
How are you supposed to know whether or not cats and you,
if you've still got one hanging out?
So you want to know if you're allergic to cats,
you have 10 cats,
you give up all 10 of your cats,
but like Saturday morning you like kick your heels up with the cat or Friday
night you're like,
I'm just going to have like one little cat,
right?
Whether that's pizza or a beer or whatever it is you're thinking about.
You can't accurately evaluate how these foods are impacting you if you're
including them.
Even a little bit in the plan.
So it's 100% elimination for 30 days and give it like a scientific experiment.
And if you do go off plan,
I really encourage people to start over both for the the kind of physiological
reasons,
but also because I want you to honor the commitment that you made to yourself 30
days.
So you mentioned,
uh,
obviously Paleo in there.
Is the whole 30,
just a Paleo Diet?
Are there differences?
There are significant differences.
It's based on the general framework of the Paleo Diet because the research
behind the foods that are eliminated on a paleo diet are pretty solid.
Again,
we're not saying these foods are good or bad.
We're not saying these foods are healthy or less healthy for you were saying
they're very commonly problematic to varying degrees.
And I don't know how they work for you until you do the whole 30 and do this
experiment and figure it out for yourself.
So the foods that you eliminate on the whole 30,
like grains,
legumes,
and dairy are all foods that are also off limits with the Paleo style diet.
But we do include potatoes in a whole 30,
because there were real nutrient dense food and lots of Paleo people say
potatoes don't count.
You're not allowed to do those like egg and banana pancakes that I talked about
and some of the Paleo treats and desserts that are out there.
So there are some differences.
Our program is for a very good
specific purpose.
And so,
um,
when we were talking about,
you know,
we do this whole 30,
if we make it,
thank God,
um,
what happens next?
Yeah.
So it can be scary and that's really what food freedom forever is about as
people did the whole 30.
We've had millions of people do it and they have amazing success and they feel
like they really changed their habits.
And it's like the first thing that's really worked for them and then they're
like,
okay,
now what?
Because I don't want to go back to the way that I was eating,
but I don't know how to not do that,
especially in the face of a holiday,
a vacation,
a stressful event.
So that's really what food freedom forever is about,
is it's a three step plan to help people kind of get past that short term
dietary intervention and turn what they've learned into a lifetime of health,
the habits.
So it kind of stemmed from the terror that people might feel and they're like,
oh,
I have to go back into the real world now.
The real food look like.
I mean,
maybe that's excitement,
but I think a lot of people,
it's also terrible.
It's like we call it [inaudible] excited.
It's like frightened and excited at the same time,
right?
You're excited to get back to some of the foods that you really love and see how
they work for you.
But at the same time you feel so good that you just don't want to mess it up and
you're afraid that if you do let some of these foods back in,
it's going to send you down this slippery slide of like feeling out of control
again.
And so I had a lot of,
you know,
and I've provided a lot of guidance over the years about what to do but never in
a really clear like step by step,
do this,
do that format.
So this came from my community saying,
Mike,
I need more help.
I need more help in like after the whole thing.
30 yeah.
You mentioned like the carb up Liza,
that could happen immediately following your 30 day 31 Yay.
I can have all the pasta,
but I don't think that's how it works.
All right.
Tell us about the reintroduction.
Yeah,
so we did a survey.
I think we had more than like 5,000 well 30 years respond and of those people
who finished the whole 30 and said at the beginning of their program,
they thought they were going to want to eat all the things on day 31 75% of them
at the end said,
I actually didn't want to,
I felt so different and things can change so much my tastes and change that.
I didn't want to do that.
But in between the,
the whole 30 and you're sort of food freedom comes this reintroduction period.
Remember you eliminate and then you bring them back in.
So we've got both a 10 day kind of fast track reintroduction outlined in the
whole 30 book.
And then we've got this kind of slow roll option for people who maybe don't want
to bring everything back in within 10 days.
But the reintroduction is like the money of the program.
This is where you learn how these foods impact you and where you learn,
how,
how much and how often and what kinds of foods you can bring back into your life
so that it's delicious and healthy and feels sustainable,
but in a way that's not going to mess you up in terms of how awesome you want to
look at it.
I feel great.
So,
um,
if we're slowly introducing things,
what does it look like?
Say Okay,
today is dairy day.
Do I go and eat like yogurt all day and top it off with like a dad milk and then
have a brick of cheese and ice cream?
Maybe not a brick of cheese.
Basically what you want to do.
Again,
think of it like a scientific experiment.
Dairy is going to be your experimental factor in the whole 30 is your control.
So your entire diet to the whole day is going to be whole 30 the only thing
you're adding back in his dairy.
So you would do your typical whole 30 breakfast,
maybe it's some poached eggs,
um,
maybe a little bit of avocado and like a veggie medley and some mixed berries.
But you're going to sprinkle some cheese on your eggs.
So you're going to add the dairy back in in a way that allows you to evaluate
just the dairy component alone.
And then you're going to go back to the whole 30 for two or three days and see
what happens in terms of the reaction.
Because sometimes the reaction can take a day or so to manifest,
depending on how senator sensitive
you are,
you don't
want to overdo it but slowly bring your down anytime.
Yeah.
And you have to do enough of it to really see.
So if you just put a drop of milk in your coffee,
like what are the chances that you're really going to notice an impact that you
want to do some cream in your coffee,
you know some cheese on your Omelette media side of yogurt with your lunch and
then at dinner you know some other form of dairy that you really like.
What you don't want to do is do you know a giant bowl of ice cream that also has
cookie dough that also has talked with chocolate syrup.
Cause then you're not going to know what's impacting you,
the dairy or the gluten or the massive sugar bomb.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what about people who like can,
is there some way to do this if you don't want to go strict whole 30 follow
there.
They're pretty strict guidelines.
I think that they make a lot of friends.
That's a really great to find out.
But some people are like know.
So if I said I want to do this,
but I don't care how alcohol affects me,
I don't care if it makes me blooded,
I care for him.
It makes my skin break out.
I want to try to get rid of all the other things,
bring it all in.
Can I feel do a whole 30
doing the whole 30 is a little like being pregnant.
You either are or you're not.
There's no like kind of,
right.
So you know if you're going to do the program the way I'd describe it as like if
you're going to come play my game,
you need to play by my rules and all I'm asking for is 30 days and all I'm
asking is for you to trust me for one month and I've got seven years of
experience backing up my recommendations.
But the whole 30 is not for everyone.
So if you're Vegan for example,
you can't do the whole 30 as written because we're basically excluding all of
your plant based protein sources and,
and you know,
the rules are rigid and it's a lot to imagine giving up at once.
It can be a very emotional journey.
So in food freedom forever,
I have outlined several different resets that you can do,
not all of which are as intense as the whole 30 but all of which will get you to
the place where you know how food impacts you and you're in a better balance in
terms of your blood sugar regulation,
hormonal balance,
digestion and immune system.
So the whole 30 isn't the price of admission for food freedom,
but I will strongly encourage everyone to do it and I do several times in the
book.
Awesome.
So,
um,
if you're looking to do something that your book will give you a few different
options for things,
I think,
yeah,
I did have the question as well as you know,
if I'm that Jan Degan why can't have Phil,
I have Tofu like I would usually highlight on the whole 30 strictly,
but you'd definitely give people the option.
Yeah,
there is a full vegan out Meegan Reese that outlined here and you're eliminating
the most commonly problematic vegan protein sources.
Again,
according to the literature and the,
and the,
and you know when all of the resets you're pulling out alcohol,
like,
come on guys,
you're going to hold on alcohol for 30 days.
Right?
And all of the resets,
you're eliminating added sugar and some of those process to kind of food with no
breaks and some of those sweet treats and desserts and baked goods like all of
the resets.
That's kind of the very baseline.
I'd be elimination.
There's a basic reset outlined in here that's like as bare bones as possible.
But what I say in the book with all sorts of tough love,
emphasis on the love is if you're not willing to do at least this,
like you're not ready for this,
this
program right now.
That's fair.
I liked the top lab and the buckets.
Yes,
of course.
That's very real.
You give a test,
right?
So yeah,
I very much appreciate that.
Have you ever had anybody go through the whole 30 program and do the whole,
the introduction?
I just like,
I don't notice anything different.
Like I don't notice any of my allergies flare up or whatever.
The whole time.
Is it anything like that?
Sometimes,
you know,
the whole 30 doesn't work super well for absolutely everybody.
For some people,
food may not be your biggest issue.
If you've already been eating really squeaky clean or close to whole 30 ish and
you're already,
you know,
pretty healthy.
Like maybe there's something else going on.
Maybe it's because you're only sleeping five hours a night or your overtreat you
know,
you're doing today crossfit sessions and not recovering actively.
So,
you know,
food might not be your biggest issue.
The whole 30 also can't fix everything.
So if you've got this,
you know,
underlying undiagnosed got infection or you've got an autoimmune condition that
you've been living with and it's been progressing for the last 20 years,
like the whole 30 might give you a good start towards feeling better,
but you may need to work with a functional medicine doctor to make sure you know
that you're getting the treatment that's applicable for you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
Um,
the other thing that I think can be problematic is that whole thing around
social networks,
families.
How do you navigate that?
I know like going to my mom and say,
ah,
I'm not even written gay.
I'm not having,
Oh God,
I'm not.
She'll just be like,
oh,
don't come home.
Right.
What do we do?
So not what you just said.
That's a terrible way to do.
I actually have three chapters in food freedom forever about how to talk to
friends,
family and coworkers about food.
Three chapters,
not overkill because talking to friends and family about food is third only to
religion and politics in terms of how divisive it can be.
You know,
you start talking about food and changing your diet and immediately people get
judgmental,
they get defensive.
Like you don't have to do anything.
You can just roll up to the table with your whole 30 meal on the entire table.
All of a sudden it feels like it's being attacked.
So you know what I like to,
what I like to say is a,
don't have the conversation over food,
right?
Have it away from food.
And ideally ahead of time be you always want to lead with all of the positive
things and you want to make the conversation as personal as is appropriate for
your relationships.
So if you're talking to your mom and you say,
you know,
I hear the whole 30 is really good for cravings,
that's not going to particularly bring you close together.
If you say,
mom,
you know you sent me home with your chocolate chip cookies the other day and I
said I was only gonna eat one and I ended up eating five and it makes me feel
really bad.
I'm on myself that I can't control what I'm eating.
So I'm going to do this experiment for 30 days where I tried to kind of break my
reliance on sugar and change my cravings.
It means I won't be able to eat your cookies,
but it's only for a month.
And when I get done I'll be able to really enjoy them the way you want me to
write.
That's a totally different conversation.
So make it personal and then make it relatable.
So if your mom is mostly sedentary,
you saying,
I'm going to do the whole 30 and I'm hoping to cut my five k time by three
minutes.
Not if you know your mom also suffers from cravings or sleep or energy issues,
you know,
bond with her and that level man,
every day at two o'clock my head's on my desk and I feel like I need caffeine
and chocolate.
You know what I mean?
Oh yeah,
me too.
I'm going to do this whole 30 because it's really meant to kind of reset your
energy levels and give you that sort of awake feeling without meeting extra
caffeine and now she's like listening,
right?
So those are my best tips is that you also say maybe you should do it with
valor.
Tread very carefully with that.
You guys,
you know the phrase I like to use as lead by quiet example.
You can ask for her support and I'm,
will you support me in this?
If I'm having a tough day,
can I call you and have you tell me what a good job I'm doing?
But you don't want to ever push someone into trying to do it right.
Instead just lead by quiet example.
Look awesome.
I feel awesome.
Talk about your results here.
Non scale victories.
Hey Mom,
you know I saw a plate of cookies at the office today and I wasn't even tempted.
I feel so good.
What a great you know,
sign that is.
And then just the back because at some point they will say like,
what have you been doing?
Tell me a little more about it and maybe it will take them a while to get there.
But you know,
you just do you
talk to me a little bit more about non scale victories because I think our
society is really obsessed with like that number that appears on it.
How do you get away from that?
What are the,
what are things to fellows?
I mean that's a good example.
Yeah.
And away from the cookies,
I think
it's huge.
And so one of the other rules of the whole 30 is that you're not allowed to step
on the scale for 30 days,
which for sun is the hardest rule of them all.
But it is not a weight loss program and it is not about weight and I am,
you know,
I think we all need a break from letting us like $20 a hunk of plastic hold our
self esteem and self confidence hostage.
So we focus on what we call non scale victories and in hole 30 lingo it's
Hashtag Nsbe and what people will do is look for things like you know,
maybe some of them are physical,
maybe it's Oh I I'm down a belt loop or the my wedding ring now fits it was too
small and now it fits.
I love hearing that.
Maybe it's a craving thing.
Like I didn't need the cook.
I was able to walk past the cookie year.
I didn't need the candy bar.
Or I finally feel like I'm in control of food.
Maybe it's digestive,
maybe it's skin glowing and clearing up.
We hear a lot of that,
you know,
maybe it's I went to my doctor and my blood sugar is that are managed or I'm no
longer type two diabetic.
But there is this huge list of non scale victories in a pdf we give you on the
whole 30 sheet and it's like check them off people because the more you can
check off,
the more motivated you'll be to continue.
And so even after the whole 30,
is it still no scale or you like ethics gal?
Um,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm anti scale if getting on that number actually matters.
If you like with trepidation,
close your eyes and cross your fingers before you step on that scale.
Maybe it's better to get off the scale.
I have a scale at my house,
I use it to weigh my suitcases,
68 pounds for this trip,
68,
uh,
or two way my son.
And occasionally I'll step on and just kind of see where I am.
But like it doesn't mean anything.
So I am okay with weighing yourself before and after because for some people you
know,
obviously understand weight loss is a big goal for a lot of people and I don't
want to minimize how amazing it is.
If you can eat just the tidy and not count calories and still lose weight like
awesome.
But you know,
if that number is going to ruin your day or make your day,
maybe you should examine your relationship.
But the scale only pair really fair in terms of other sort of technologies.
I mean we're good,
all we kinda care about that.
Are there things that you're onboard with?
Again,
things that are helpful but fine.
I'll like that.
Fitness trackers.
Wearables.
Yeah,
guys like the posture coach and
all of those four that you mentioned in your before.
Yeah,
I don't know about the Hapi fork.
It vibrates to let you know if you're eating too quickly.
So,
but it's like 80 bucks.
So I'm like maybe you could just stop eating like you're in prison.
You know,
one of my favorite card,
I do like the wearables.
If you are the kind of person who is motivated by like seeing your results,
then things that can improve on the whole 30 or that you'll notice is like
naturally your steps will go up because you'll feel better and you'll want to be
more active and you'll park further away and you won't sweat taking the stairs.
So like that's cool.
Your sleep quality can be able to track your sleep and whether you're falling
asleep easy or sleeping longer,
getting more restful sleep,
awesome.
Non Scale victory on the whole 30 so if you can find some of those little kind
of ways to not only track your progress but like tie it to like,
oh wow.
It's stuff that you wouldn't necessarily,
I guess link back to your diet,
taking more stuffs.
But if you see a change in that it can be really motivated.
Yeah.
I have one last question for you before I open it up to everybody who's probably
dying to ask you things like stop talking,
but I'm curious about just changing the whole relationship about good and bad
foods and how do you even like get to that spot?
Because I think it's hard.
It's very hard for people to know that,
you know,
it's not necessarily like this is good for you,
this is bad for you or you're a good person or a bad person.
You talked a lot about the language of food.
How do we change that?
Really important.
I think the language of food is often what's holding us hostage and our
relationship and what I really emphasize in the whole 30 and often feed freedom.
It's like these foods that you're eliminating.
It's not because they're bad,
there's no like good or bad food.
You're pulling them out and putting them back in because they're unknown.
That's it.
You just want to figure out how they work for you and you are not good or bad
based on the food that you put on your plate.
And I think once we can get past the idea of,
you know,
be our self worth being tied to what our body weight is or what size of jeans we
fit into or whether we are the exercise or or the healthy person.
I think it makes a huge difference in letting food be more fun and easy and
playful and rewarding and like a joyful,
I'm not trying to take any of that away,
so I write a lot about the idea of a growth mindset and changing your language
and just kind of,
it's a real shift or reframe with from the Diet Culture we've had for the last
20 years where it was all about deprivation and restriction and willpower and
good foods and bad foods.
And like,
I want to change all of that paradigm,
but learning to kind of think about it in a different way than you do.
I mean it just seems so high,
but I think that you give a lot of great tips in the buck,
soiled them all.
But yeah,
I think it's a challenge that that needs to be solved.
So related to like the goods and the bads.
Yeah.
But you know,
the more you practice that and,
and I talk about things like leaving postit notes around your house.
Like,
it sounds kind of silly,
but the more you can reinforce the ideas behind,
you know,
I'm a healthy person with healthy habits and I'm living a healthy lifestyle and
this is a scientific experiment.
It's an experiment.
It's not a diet and the more you can kind of reframe and I really emphasize that
over and over again,
I think the better chance you have of that actually sticking and,
and changing your foods and changing your relationship with foods and feeling
like you're building new healthy habits will only serve to reinforce.
That's great.
All right guys,
open it up.
We have [inaudible] right.
Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
This is really interesting.
And as someone who's like generally a health focused eater but also kind of
hasn't ever really dieted.
Um,
I was wondering if you could elaborate a little bit more on your last point
there about the idea of like,
after you're done with the whole 30 kind of not putting,
thinking about foods is good and bad because I know I've,
you know,
I don't know too much about the whole 30 but I've seen periods where people like
on my Facebook or whatever doing it.
And to me it always kind of worries me the idea of saying like,
you can't have these things.
Um,
and you know,
it seems a little bit sad if after the whole 30 would end then you still feel
like I can't have,
you know,
the cookies I can't have,
even if you end up being okay with dairy and eggs.
Um,
and you know,
eating disorders are also a thing that like happens too.
So I guess what's your perspective on after people finished the whole 30 and
they figured out what they can and can't have then transitioning to be like,
okay,
like now we're going to bake pumpkin cookies and like I'm going to have one and
that's okay.
That's a really great question.
And that's so much of that all or nothing is the Diet mentality,
right?
I need,
they're on this diet and I'm white knuckling my way through it or on face first
in a box of donuts.
And so I start from the very beginning,
from your elimination period with the whole 30 saying,
you're not eliminating these foods because they're bad.
They're just unknown and you just want to figure out how they work for you.
And it's not the whole three 65 it's the whole 30 so it's a 30 day kind of
scientific elimination period.
And then after that I want you to live in your food freedom.
I want you to figure out what does work for you and what doesn't.
In fact,
the goal I propose in food freedom forever is this.
I want your diet to be as broad and expansive as possible while still looking
and feeling as awesome as you want to look and feel and you get to draw outline.
I'm not drawing it for you.
So I have figured out that I can get away with a couple of glasses of wine here
and there.
Some Justin's peanut butter cups here and there my mom's chocolate chip walnut
cake and like still look just as awesome and I still feel just as awesome.
So guess what I do because it makes my life so delicious and healthy and
rewarding and happy,
like emotionally healthy.
So I want you to do that.
And if you start from the beginning not thinking about these foods as bad and
that's why you're eliminating them,
then you shouldn't feel the same guilt when you bring them back in.
I don't want you to feel guilty reintroducing these foods.
You may make the wrong choice.
Sometimes I may overdo it on the wine or my mom's chocolate chip while my cake
and I'm like,
wow,
that was a poor decision.
You know,
I don't feel as good and my energy's down,
my mood is down.
Okay.
So I learned from that and I apply it the next time that situation comes up.
But I encourage everyone to find that like line,
how much can you get away with so that your life is amazing and rewarding and
delicious and satisfying and full of your family and friends traditions while
still maintaining all of the health benefits you want to maintain.
So yeah,
thanks.
Just to follow up on that,
what if you do overdo it and just like completely fall off after you've done
your health?
So one of the steps in food freedom forever,
so it's,
you know,
you do your reset,
you live your food freedom and you acknowledged that your habits have slept.
So I have built right into the plan that you will fall off the wagon.
Isn't that relieving?
Because all of these diets are like,
oh,
you're going to do our 21 day detox and then you'll never ever have to dye it
ever again.
And like everything's going to be magically changed.
And that's completely unrealistic even for a program as good as the whole 30 and
it's good and changing people's habits.
Eventually you fall back into old ruts,
your trend to overwrite decades of less healthy behaviors and associations and
emotional relationships with food.
You're not going to fix that in 30 days.
So if that happens,
you just come back to your reset,
whether it's a full whole 30 or maybe a whole three or a whole seven,
however long you need to feel back in control and to get that,
you know,
energy and sleep and mood and digestion,
rock and again,
cool.
You know,
it works.
You know how to do it,
you know it's gonna make you feel amazing.
And then as soon as you're done,
as soon as you're able to,
as soon as possible,
because I want you to get right back to your food freedom.
You're back to living in your normal healthy balance again.
It's like simple.
And you continue that cycle literally in perpetuity until ideally you never need
another whole 30 ever again.
I'll probably never do a full 30 ever again.
No,
I don't need it right each time.
Of course it does.
It gets easier.
You learn more.
You become more selective about what's worth it for you.
You identify foods that maybe don't work for you,
but it's really nuanced,
you know,
oh,
I didn't notice this after my first whole 30,
but by my third,
I don't think this is worth it anymore.
Yeah.
It gets easier and it just becomes what you do.
You no longer even have to think about it.
Yeah.
Cool.
Hey,
my name is Brooke.
Thanks so much for coming.
Um,
I'm on day 10 of whole 30 run for Yay back.
I've done it.
This is my fourth time.
Um,
I started a year ago and I swear to God,
it's like completely changed my life.
So if anyone's doubting,
like you absolutely have to try it.
Um,
I don't do the gluten or the dairy or alcohol anymore and it's completely
changed my life.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
so with all of these resets and then having over the course of the year,
decided to eliminate those things.
The one thing that does change it does kind of keep me going back to old 30 is
the fact that like the sugar thing sneaks in.
So if it's like our fucking,
sorry,
I love gummies.
Um,
and I love like,
um,
almond milk,
ice cream and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Um,
but I noticed that actually interestingly enough,
like I lost a lot of weight at the beginning and then eliminating all the foods
that affect me poorly.
My weight's actually kind of gone back up.
I'm wondering what maybe like the scientific reason for that is and if it is the
sugar,
like,
I mean that would make sense,
but like I've heard also before perhaps that like your body kind of like level
sets and like kind of recalibrates after,
um,
you know,
you kind of eliminate all these things.
I was just wondering if you could speak to that.
Yeah,
there's like a million questions that would have to ask you.
So,
you know,
do you have a history of Yoyo dieting where you like lose and kind of gain kind
of,
uh,
how,
how long were you sleeping every single night?
What are you doing for exercise?
Is it high intensity stuff?
Are you adequately recovering from that?
What is your life stress look like?
Like we would sit down and have like a serious therapy session for me to talk
about.
Maybe it's the food,
maybe you know a food journal can be very helpful in this situation because I
might say,
do you like how are you?
How are you eating after your whole 30 book and you're like,
I'm doing pretty well.
And then if I made you write down every single thing like that,
weighing or measuring,
just write it down.
You're like,
oh wow.
That new bar and almond milk ice creams coming back like a couple of times a
week.
And you know,
we were having a conversation before about the planes,
the bags of plantain chips.
You think they're healthy.
If you Hoover one of those,
it is like 560 calories and it's not,
the calories don't count.
Right?
So you know,
it's basically like a mini meal all unto itself.
So maybe a food journal,
maybe it's the food,
but maybe food isn't your biggest issue anymore.
And maybe it's time to look at things like caffeine consumption in sleep or how
what you're doing for training and recovery or what's going on with your life
stress.
I know a lot of people who go on vacation and immediately they lose like 10
pounds even though their eating habits dramatically change.
And I'm like,
well,
shocking.
You have no stress on vacation.
Everything's easy and simple.
So there's just so many factors that kind of play into that.
Consider keeping a journal just for a few days after your whole 30 just to see
if stuff is kind of sneaking back in and then maybe consider going to work with
a functional medicine doctor.
Doing some very basic testing could be an underlying undiagnosed,
got infection for example,
really common in some these cases.
So it could be a number of things,
but it's not always food.
And I find when people do multiple whole thirties they kind of want to tie
everything back to food and like food's a huge part of it,
but it's not the only part.
Thank you.
Yeah,
you're welcome.
And good luck.
Okay.
Awesome.
Thanks for coming.
Uh,
two questions.
First one is the simple one,
just when you travel,
how do you prepare for that and what foods do you personally have?
A,
the second one is more just like,
I'm curious on your journey to actually write this book and like be interested
in this because I had tons of dietary issues earlier and I was placed on the low
FODMAP diet.
It's just like whole 30 but stricter and it was phenomenal change in my life.
Now I'm like very paleo with a side of sugar.
And so just curious how you got to this point.
Was it like you hit some mark and then you were like,
wow,
I need to change my life?
No,
I did.
Uh,
I'll answer the first question first about travel.
I,
so I,
my bag on the way to for this book tour was 68 pounds and I'm pretty sure six
times and that were meat sticks,
like a Turkey sticks.
So I always pack a ton of emergency food and I've had a really healthy protein
because that's the hardest thing to find when you're traveling.
It's easy to find fruit and nuts and seeds.
But,
so I'm packing like epic bars and wild bars and DNX bars and like the meat,
you know,
sticks.
I've got literally anyone wants to try one and got like seven in my bag right
now.
Um,
I do as much research as I can ahead of time.
So when I land,
I know where the local health food store is.
I know where the local grocery story is.
I know a few good lunch options.
I've already looked at the menu to make sure I can kind of wing it like anywhere
at this point that I still want to,
you know,
make it as easy on myself as possible so that when I get there I already have
kind of a plan and I'm not like stuck in rush hour traffic after a really long
flight,
super hangry with no where to go for food.
I make sure that my hotel has a refrigerator so I can stock up on a few things
at the grocery store.
Um,
so those are some tips that kind of make it easier.
I wrote an article called business travel one on one oh one on whole thirty.com
that lays out my incredibly anal retentive travel plan because I travel so much
and it's really important to me to make it as stress free as possible.
As for my journey,
um,
I was not always a really healthy person.
I'm actually a recovering drug addict.
I've been clean for almost 17 years and that
flat for that,
like I got myself messed up so I'm not sure you should applaud me getting messed
up,
but it's,
it is a big deal.
And I started in health and exercise and nutrition when I got out of Rehab
because I knew that I had to change everything about my life to stay clean.
I had to adopt that growth mindset and convince myself that I wasn't some
degenerate,
worthless loser who couldn't change her life.
So I started exercising and I started eating healthier and I got some fitness
certifications and ran a crossfit gym for a while and did some Kettlebell
coaching.
And that was really where my path started was through my own transformation.
And so if you've done the whole 30 knowingness about my background,
like the rules kind of makes sense.
The rigidity kind of makes sense.
The sort of steps in the community kind of makes sense because it was all of the
things that I needed to get and stay clean 17 years ago.
So yeah,
there's a chapter on that here because if you looked at me now,
I think a lot of people would say like,
what do you know about feeling out of control with your food?
I've never been overweight.
That's not a struggle or a battle I fought.
But trust me when I say I had fought my battles and drugs and food are not that
different in terms of the impact they have on the brain and cravings and reward
and your social interactions and your self confidence.
And so I do.
Right.
Thanks.
Just follow up quickly on the,
um,
the food,
going out to eat vacations,
that sorta thing.
Um,
I think one of the great things about Google,
there's 90 is that we had got a menu every day and we see all of the things
that's a bit better available to us and it gives you all of the allergens.
But when you go to a restaurant,
you don't have that.
So people who are not in this world,
like,
how do you navigate?
Are you,
what do you say?
How do you go out for dinner?
Yeah,
this is totally my process.
The first thing I do is go on Yelp and I look at,
and I do a search for like American new or grass fed burger or vegetarian
breakfast because for some reason the vegetarian breakfasts tend to kind of lead
me to like the grass fed organic kind of farm to table places.
I look at the menu.
If the menu looks pretty doable,
I'm looking for simple protein options.
So it's like a steak or grilled fish or eggs or a burger.
Like,
cool.
I look at the sides.
Do I have a bunch of Veggie choices?
Like great.
Um,
occasionally if I have to,
I'll call the restaurant ahead of time and say,
look,
I'm walking in like this is my stuff and I don't make a big deal out of it.
I don't eat this,
this or this right now.
Uh,
do you have options that would accommodate me or when I come in,
can I make some requests?
I had a lamb burger at the Breslin last night,
so good.
But they don't do substitutions.
That's very helpful to know upfront.
So I walked in and you know,
I did no been no cheese and they did that,
but they wouldn't substitute my salad dressing for a different dressing cause it
was cream based.
So I just asked for lemon and a little bit of olive oil and they were cool with
that.
But it's good to know ahead of time.
So just do your research ahead of time and then when you get there,
you know,
make your order and be as matter of fact and kind of polite as possible.
The bigger a deal you make about it,
the bigger a deal everyone else is going to make like so don't walk in there and
be like,
oh,
I know it's so weird and I'm going to be your special person and I'm so sorry.
Like,
no,
can I have this?
Then can I not have the button and not have cheese?
And can you sum the fries for,
I see you've got Broccoli in this dish.
Can I just get some Broccoli steamed on the side?
Thank you so much.
And then you tip very generously.
That was actually one of my questions.
But the other question is how do you find the right time to do this?
I always feel like,
oh,
I can't,
this month I have two client events or I can't next month it's,
you know,
thanksgiving or like how do you find or prioritize the right 30 days to start?
That's a really great question.
So first of all,
you want to remember that it's not just 30 days,
it's 30 days plus reintroductions.
So I see people sometimes we were like,
oh my day 31 is my trip to Italy.
And I'm like,
Ooh,
you're really gonna have a hard time reintroducing there.
And if you don't reintroduce,
you're missing a lot of the benefit of the program.
So what ideally you're finding a 40 day block.
I want you to not do the whole 30 ideally over the holidays.
Like that's just right.
That's just like asking for trouble.
Plus during the holidays you've got a lot of these like once a year,
really special family foods and I don't necessarily want you to miss out on
that.
So find a 40 day block where you don't have like an a level raise or you're not
getting married that month or you don't have a once in a lifetime vacation to
Croatia.
But a client event is not a good enough reason.
I want you to figure out how to do this and all of life's circumstances,
bridal showers,
family dinners,
client events,
business lunches,
like you need to figure out how to live in your food freedom,
which may or may not include these foods going forward.
So don't schedule around.
You'll never find 40 days where the only thing you're doing is staying at home.
Watching Netflix,
like that's not going to happen,
so make sure it's nothing that's so special.
You won't want to miss it,
but I would include some of those kind of every day,
but still special ish occurrences and then figure out how to make it work.
Right.
You're ordering a sparkling water with lime and your justice festive and you're
just as cheersing and it's just as happy in that hour.
Yeah.
Hi.
Thanks for coming.
Yeah,
three and a half years in counting and loving it and loving every minute of it.
I have one situation that continues to be challenging,
which is at this point,
pretty much everyone in my life knows that I have eating habits that they might
consider a quirky or bizarre or a bit,
get us a convention wisdom or whatever it is.
Yeah.
Occasionally I'm a guest in someone's house,
which happened actually this weekend where,
oh,
you can eat everything.
It's all gluten free and full of honey and artificial sweeteners and rice flour
and all kinds of things that I'm not going near.
Um,
how do you prepare for,
well I know how I prepare internally,
but how do you prepare socially for those situations and handle those with a
well meaning host who is actually going against everything that you want.
I totally get that.
And I had that situation at,
at the holidays this past year where I was served to pasta full of ricotta
cheese and was like,
oh,
this is going to be tough.
Uh,
are you on the whole 30 during this situation or is this just your food freedom
part of your free treat?
Your,
okay,
so you're not on the whole 30.
So this is one of those situations where you have to kind of way sticking to
your preferences versus really hurting someone's feelings.
Ideally you're having a conversation ahead of time if at all possible.
Hey,
I just want to let you know,
you know,
just like if you were a vegetarian for example,
I just want to let you know that I don't eat this,
this,
and this.
That's going to be a problem with your menu.
I'd be to bring in Dash,
let me know what I could contribute when you get there.
You know,
if they've gone out of the way and said this is all gluten free,
but it's full of this other stuff,
then it comes down to how bad is it gonna mess you up.
If it's going to seriously mess you up with migraines or headaches or are as
not,
or whatever,
then you have to politely decline and say,
you know what,
I really would love to and I'm so,
so thankful that you took the time to prepare this,
but I really have a bad reaction with artificial sweeteners and if I eat it,
this is going to happen.
So I'll politely decline.
But thank you so much.
If it's just a preference,
okay,
then you have to think about like I might just take one for the team and eat as
little as possible as to be polite,
uh,
share with someone else,
pass your plate onto someone else,
take a bite or two and say,
this was amazing.
Thank you so much,
but I'm saving for the next course if you know it's more edible,
but this is where you kind of have to weigh like hurting someone's feelings and
being gracious against what is really just a preference and not an actual like
sensitivity.
So I ate three bites of this pasta with ricotta and I knew the dairy was going
to kill me.
Like I spent the rest of the night not feeling well,
but it was a woman I didn't know.
I didn't have any opportunity to communicate.
I ate a couple of bites,
I passed it along and said,
you know,
I'm really saving for the next course,
which I knew I could totally eat and I stepped it up and took it.
And so sometimes you just kind of have to decide what's worth it for you.
Yeah.
Great.
Um,
my wife doesn't eat eggs and I was wondering what kind of like interesting
options for breakfast that uh,
you would do during that whole 30.
I love that question.
We get that question all the time.
In fact,
in the whole 30 book,
there's a whole like intro about what you can eat for breakfast if you're not
eating at [inaudible].
So,
um,
first of all,
I really encourage people to get the idea of breakfast,
lunch,
dinner out of your head.
We just call them meal one,
meal two and meal three.
And for meal one,
I'm just as likely to have a burger as I am to have an Omelet.
The other morning I literally cooked in Burger from I get and I like that was
our rec fest and it was amazing.
So,
um,
you can have absolutely anything you want leftovers for breakfast or uh,
you know,
cook any kind of protein that you want,
but if you want more of a breakfast,
he feel we do have some really good recipes.
So think things like,
you know,
ground chicken and apples and sweet potato and a few diced walnuts with like a
little apple cider vinegar,
like a warm hash style,
you know,
sausage,
whether it's pork sausage,
ideally pastured organic or some kind of chicken sausage would be a good choice.
Um,
soups in the morning or good.
I also love a good breakfast salad,
which I know sounds weird,
but I got into the habit of eating salad first thing in the morning when I was
in Scandinavia and just fell in love with the idea.
So meeting breakfast salads with some sort of protein on top of that,
just feel dip.
So almost so different that it's like cool that you're reading it for breakfast,
but there are a lot of,
you just Google whole 30 egg free breakfasts,
you will come up with a million different ideas from our community.
Okay.
Yeah.
Any other questions from the audience?
Not that gives us perfect time for you guys to get the book,
get some signing gun and that we want to thank you so much for being here.
Yeah,
you all for having me.
This was really fun.